lucas giolito on for his 27th start
looking for his 10th win as era of 368.
he'd like to get off to a very quick
start
camel
runs
and he's going to steal the bag and head
to third
his first stolen base of the season
one out for brian reynolds
and this is popped up third base side
foul ground joan does have a backhand
effort for route number two so now
you're looking at moran as the one guy
stands in the way of lucas and getting
out of this first inning
to third moncada great reaction joan
pegg is there and the innings over and
steve that was a brilliant effort by
lucas wilson makes his fifth pirate
start 0-2 a 360 era for pittsburgh
to first fairball tracing the line into
the corner for extra bases
go on to second it's a one-out double
golfed out toward left center
reynolds has it monkata tags
standing in at third but there with two
outs
weak tapper
defoe with the toss across and they get
out of it so both teams threaten in the
first but failed to score
nothing nothing grew up the lead-off
walk for stallings
called strike three change up bottom of
the zone cascading in for route number
one one two
struck him out that's the biting slider
from lucas
swinging a miss on change up right down
the middle
for strike three the osmani grand all
leads off the sox second
scoreless tie
yes gives this a charge into left field
he did it again
rocket fuel in that bed for 24
and it's one nothing sucks
i hope we get a chance to see the look
on wilson's face when that ball went out
of the park
because if you pitch for pittsburgh
you're not used to the ball flying out
to left field like that
looped over third and
reigning down out of the reach of newman
garcia's gonna go for two the throw is
high he is low and he is saved
on the ground park
back up off of it to get the funnel out
strike three on a slider to the
left-hander gammel fourth strikeout for
giolito
and hits this in the air the other way
that's going to drop in for a base hit
putting runners at first and second one
two on the ground right side abreu
circles and has the final out of the
third inning jose hitting 3 24 this
month in his career he has batted 334 in
august
high in the air deep right field abreu
is out of here
this sox team is starting to hit a lot
of home run and jose abreu drives in as
hundred and second by driving in himself
which is a slider is getting a whole lot
sharper as he moves along
like that oh yeah
fifth strikeout for giolito
that was a fastball lifted to right
goodwin you know one two three inning
for lucas giolito his first of the night
out to center
this warning track power and that i
think for the white sox
it's a one two three in a carosa
[Applause]
he's going to beat out that change up
dribbled in front of home plate and it
just badly enough to move up park and
get aboard with the base hit i hope
lucas is okay i hope he didn't hurt his
knee
that's going to get a run in
park scores and now gamble in scoring
position after a second wild pitch
lucas's knee is not all that great right
now he's trying to stretch it out and he
just walked behind the mound yeah little
something's not quite right so gia lito
is going to leave the game at 3-1 on
defoe it's a two to one score
see if colin moran can turn one around
and that one is into right
gammel gonna be waved home
and he is gonna score on that hit by
colin moran he ties the game here in the
fifth three and two
he struck him out right back to the
slider and the inning's over
here's the pitch
ground ball second park has it throws
onto first for the out well done end of
the sixth michael kopeck comes into this
one
strike three slider kopeck started the
inning with a strikeout
and he finishes the inning with a
strikeout
a one
on the ground at third the backhand side
for defoe he fires and high abreu beats
it out
[Applause]
broken bat flare
that dunks down and the sox will have
first and third if abreu gets there and
he does
the base hit from jimenez
yaz takes ball four and the bases are
loaded with nobody out for the socks
three and two shreve to goodwin
it is ball four
and the sox have the lead three to two
[Music]
in the ear to right
tucker makes the catch jimenez tags from
third and scores and the sox get another
run on a sac fly from leori garcia eloy
says hello crowd and the sox take a
two-run lead
[Applause]
to second hernandez gives ground to one
two three inning on the ground for aaron
buffer
center cut but popped up
park says
i'll back track on it
and the inning is over one two three
against nick mears
there's a big inning for kim two and two
on moran
he struck out curveball from kimbrell
stallings to center robert on the run
luis yes he did super human stuff again
it looks like kansas city from last year
gave up the body to make the catch
what a play
all right popped him up
there it is strand of man now the bucks
bats need to get going
2-0
robert comes charging in and robert is
there on a slide a casual slide
to second base cesar and laori and a
double play
the sox bullpen was marvelous behind g.o
tonight and a 4-2 final score